this machine is the assisted dips to
change the weight you pull the yellow
pin out and place it in the selected
weight the next step is to adjust the
knee pad by pulling the yellow pin out
pulling the knee pad up and releasing
the yellow pin back in
to mount the machine you step on both
steps provided and then lift one knee up
followed by the other
you want to then gradually lower
yourself down ensuring that your elbows
are kept at around 90 degrees and then
gradually push yourself back up staying
in control of the movement it is
important to not lock your elbows out
during this movement in order to prevent
injury
this machine targets the triceps
[Music]
and also to avoid injury ensure that you
keep your core tight to not put pressure
on the lower back
to Dismount the machine similar to the
assisted chin
you want to remove one leg off of the
machine onto the step slowly bring the
knee up and then remove the other knee
and step off the machine
[Music]